wenn deine Jungpflanzen so aussehen dann
bist du hier genau richtig ich erzähle
euch jetzt nämlich was hier schief
gegangen ist und wie man vermeidet dass
die jungen Pflänzchen so lang gezogen
und schwächlich und man nennt das in der
gärtnersprache vergeilt Aussehen
eigentlich wollen wir ja möglichst
kräftige Jungpflanzen vorziehen die
ungefähr so aussehen und wenn das hier
passiert also wenn eure jungen
Pflänzchen so ganz lang gezogen oft auch
nicht so ganz grün sondern so ein
bisschen blass aussehen und schwächlich
dann liegt das vor allem an zwei Sachen
einmal haben die Pflanzen einfach nicht
genug Licht Pflanzen brauchen ja nicht
um Foto sind diese betreiben zu können
und wenn sie davon nicht genug bekommen
dann wachsen sie dem Licht entgegen ich
hatte meine z.B hier an dem Fenster
stehen aber das ist einfach zu dunkel
gewesen dann ist das hier passiert hier
sind zum Beispiel
kapuzinerkressepflanzen einfach völlig
in die Höhe geschossen weil sie
natürlich möglichst schnell zum Licht
hinkommen wollen weil sie Foto sind hier
so betreiben wollen um Energie zu
bekommen das wird dann dazu dass die
Zellen der Pflanzen ganz schwach werden
und dass die Pflanzen einfach umkippen
und ihr Gewicht gar nicht mehr halten
können und das ist natürlich überhaupt
nicht das was wir wollen dagegen helfen
zwei Sachen einmal könnt ihr eure
Pflanzen an einen möglichst sonniges
Südfenster stellen das ist aber früh im
Jahr so sagen wir bis Anfang April immer
noch ein bisschen heikel also meine
Erfahrung nach werden selbst die
Pflanzen die ich am sonnigsten
Südfenster meine Wohnung vorziehe immer
noch nicht so kräftig wie die Pflänzchen
die bei mir unter den Anzucht Lampen
stehen bitte traurige Wahrheit man kann
das natürlich auch ohne Anzucht Lampen
machen gerade jetzt wenn man mehr Strom
sparen möchte es gibt allerdings auch
LED Anzucht Lampen die gar nicht so viel
Energie fressen mein Sohn baut den
Pflanzen gerade eine Stütze ist das
eigentlich passiert bei uns dass wir die
Pflanzen so vernachlässigt haben keine
Ahnung du hast die irgendwie vergessen
und ich auch
der andere große Faktor ist die
Temperatur ich hatte meine Pflanzen hier
im Esszimmer stehen und während wir
krank waren habe ich die einfach vor
sich hinwachsen lassen und total
vernachlässigt ist es natürlich viel zu
warm also wir hier so 19 Grad würde ich
sagen Jungpflänzchen sollten sobald sie
aufgegangen sind so ungefähr bei 16 17
Grad stehen ich habe dafür eigentlich
eine Zimmer wo ich kaum Heizung wo ich
einfach so ein Regal stehen habe da sind
auch Anzucht Lampen da kriegen die
Pflanzen die richtige Temperatur und das
richtige Licht ich war nur in dem Fall
einfach zu doof die Pflanzen dahin zu
tragen jetzt ist natürlich auch noch die
große Frage können wir die noch retten
was würdest du sagen
ja die sehen gut aus
aber zum Beispiel die hier glaube ich
nicht mehr was passiert wenn wir die
einfach so auspflanzen dass dir dann
erstmal weiter
hin gesund und du müssen es glaube ich
halt auch schon gewohnt sein noch mehr
die Breite zu wachsen für Salat ihr
müsst eure Pflanzen nicht wegschmeißen
die werden halt nicht so prächtig und
kräftig wie wir das eigentlich vorhatten
aber da werden immer noch Pflanzen also
die werden jetzt nicht das liegen
sterben außer ihr habt die komplett im
Dunklen stehen gehabt das Wichtige ist
nur wenn man merkt dass man was falsch
gemacht hat dass man es eben dann jetzt
richtig macht also zieht ihr eure
Pflanzen um an einen möglichst sonnigen
Ort und bevor ihr das macht wird noch
meine Runde pikiert dann nehmt ihr die
Pflanzen aus der Erde raus und dann
setzt ihr die noch mal tiefer in die
Erde ein dafür nehmen wir jetzt hier die
Pflanzen mit einem kleinen Hölzchen raus
und versuchen die möglichst tief wieder
einzusetzen dann machen wir ein großes
Loch und können die auch ganz vorsichtig
mal hier so ein bisschen reinschlängeln
und dann einen Graben wichtig ist dass
der Stängel dabei nicht knickt
und hier haben wir wieder ein tiefes
Loch gemacht versenken unsere Pflanze
dann möglichst bis zu den Blättern wenn
es geht drin der Topf ist jetzt einfach
nicht tief genug bzw ich habe die
Pflanzen einfach zu sehr vernachlässigt
aber so geht es der schon wieder besser
als wenn sie so komplett lang gezogen
ist wenn ihr eure jungen Pflanzen am
Fenster vorziehen wollt ohne Anzucht
Lampen dann könnt ihr euch so einen
kleinen Reflektor bauen einfach mit ein
paar Schaschlik stehen oder kleine
Stäbchen und dann ja Aluminiumfolie oder
einfach einen weißen Stück Pappe das
steckt ihr dann auf der dem Fenster
abgewandten Seite hinter eure Pflanzen
so dass das Licht vom Fenster zurück auf
eure Pflanzen reflektieren kann und
damit kriegt ihr schon viel kräftigere
Jungpflänzchen auch am Fenster
vorgezogen so sollten kräftige
Jungpflanzen eigentlich aussehen und
wenn ihr noch mehr Tipps wollt wie ihr
das hinbekommt dass sie so schön kräftig
und gedrungen werden dann schaut mal da
drüben vorbei da habe ich euch nämlich
ein Video zur tomatenanzucht verlinkt
bis dann macht's gut tschüss und nicht
vergessen geht raus und macht die Welt
ein bisschen grüner gefällig